lo primero que tenemos que entender es
que la debilidad de la libra y en la
necesidad de intervención del Banco
Central no tienen nada que ver con lo
que hago a veces de hacerles por un
presupuesto sino es la consecuencia de
más de una década de exceso monetario en
el que se ha estado disfrazando el
riesgo particularmente los bonos
soberanos y es un riesgo que está
apareciendo no solamente en el Reino
Unido sino también en Europa la eurozona
Noruega Japón Incluso en China lo
segundo que Debemos entender es que el
gobierno del estrés está cometiendo un
grave error al cambiar su política
fiscal simplemente por hacer una
supuesta intencionalidad de calmar a los
mercados porque lo que está dando es una
señal de debilidad y además de dar una
señal de debilidad no está entendiendo
que
el problema fiscal del Reino Unido no lo
ha creado este gobierno ni este
presupuesto sino más de una década de
estar constantemente monetizando el
déficit
por otro lado el economista opinó sobre
lo que deberían hacer otros países en
situaciones Fiscales parecidas
lo que no se debe hacer es esto que se
llama muy mal presupuestos expansivos el
presupuesto expansivo se le llama a
gastar mucho más y eso es un error y es
un error en un periodo de inflación
porque perpetúa la inflación entonces lo
que hay que hacer es reducir el gasto
público que no lo estaba haciendo ni lo
va a hacer les traes y tampoco lo están
haciendo los gobiernos del mundo parte
del problema de inflación viene de unos
gobiernos que han estado incrementando
masivamente el déficit y el gasto y
monetizandolo con impresión de Nueva
moneda por lo tanto lo que tenemos que
ver es un esfuerzo de reducción del
déficit Y por supuesto reducción del
gasto público